oh yeah Lourdes here Simona her welcome
nah
till then a press conference the biscuit
listen tiara or it's Noble please if you
see welcome to this press conference
where we will present this year's Nobel
Prize in Physics
we will keep to the traditional start in
Swedish and then continue the
presentation in English and of course
you are free to post questions in either
language when we come to the question
time yo yo hey de Stefano mark focused
and the security area had become clear
evidence cops Academy Omiya made some be
seated ahoy at Warsaw Q negan feel
secure professor Yana Engelmann would
foreign the class of a physique some
cans for a frugal clean a preset or
constructs come a brothel it Amir Auto
bernstrom a higher professor Olga
Buettner Lea the moon in Nobel Committee
and for physique or it's please harem no
grunting overtly that summer an ovule
and the Beatles come Leviathan scoffs
Academy in Havasu tattletale at photo
center add-on or noble please if you see
till professor Francois glare the
université libre de Purcell Balian
fork professor peter higgs
the University of Edinburgh stubble
Tonia Academy is motivating leader for
interior disco objectin of a mekinese
some be draw till fish stalls and or
mass ensues from whose sub a Tamara
particular or some Milligan Europe
Tecton of Danford saga fundamental a
particular the crafters of Atlas or CMS
experimental desange accelerator
él hacía this year's price is about
something very small that makes all the
difference
the Royal Swedish Academy of Sciences
has decided to award the 2013 Nobel
Prize in Physics to Professor France all
on glare at university level uber sell
the reek and Professor Peter Higgs that
you
University of Edinburgh United Kingdom
in the Academy citation runs for the
theoretical discovery of a mechanism
that contributes to our understanding of
the origin of mass of sub atomic
particles and which recently was
confirmed through the discovery of the
predicted fundamental particle by the
Atlas in simius experiments at CERN Ed's
and Large Hadron Collider professor
Canadian among will not give us a short
summary in English please
this is a triumph not only for professor
angler and professor Higgs but for
theoretical physics more generally and
actually the whole research field of
elementary particle physics it also
illustrates the scientific method namely
to formulate theories based on
mathematics in attempts to understand
the laws of nature and testing them
against experimental measurements in
1964 Francoise angler together with his
now deceased colleague Robert Brown and
Peter Higgs proposed independently of
each other
the theory to solve the fundamental
problem of how particles acquire mass
their theory became a cornerstone of the
standard model for elementary particle
physics which describes all matter as
being built of a few kinds of basic
matter particles and all forces in
nature as mediated by a few kinds of
force particles however their theory
required a totally new quantum field
which should be manifested by a new and
special kind of particle the Higgs
particle this particle has now at lost
been observed last year by the Atlas and
CMS collaborations were experiments at
the International CERN laboratory
outside Geneva in Switzerland Thank You
professor in German and now I turn to
professor olga Boatner
you ready to give a more detailed
presentation yes provided this works
well yes so this brings me to the 4th of
July 2012 which is a day that marks in
your era in particle physics and this is
not only because fans are angler and
Peter Higgs met for the first time ever
in front of a packed auditorium at CERN
but mainly because their ideas on mass
of the fundamental particles had just
been confirmed but let us start by going
50 years back in time in the autumn 1964
I'm glad together with Robert Broad who
is now no longer with us and Peter Higgs
independently published two manuscripts
explaining how certain particles can
obtain mass as you can see the
publication dates only a few months
apart in the case of Higgs October 19th
in the case of Englert and Brout
August that you want so both made a
contribution to explaining the origin of
mass and these contributions cannot be
distinguished now what they did is
central to the so-called standard model
of particle physics and let me try to
explain what the standard model of
particle physics is about by taking this
example of a fly so everything around us
and we ourselves flowers trees stars can
be described in terms in terms of a
handful of constituents of matter and
the forces acting between them
and so if you now look at the fly it
consists of molecules each molecule
consists of atoms and each atom has an
atomic nucleus and orbiting around the
nucleus we have electrons nuclei are not
fundamental particles the protons and
neutrons have interm in turn fundamental
constituents which which they believe
are indivisible and they are called
quarks now these fundamental matter
particles interact by means of forces
and within quantum mechanics we believe
that these forces are mediated by quanta
by particles and so we have the
electromagnetic force mediated by
photons which are massless we have the
weak nuclear force mediated by massive
particles which are called W and Z I'll
have the strong nuclear force mediated
by massless gluons now always well and
good except the theory behind the
standard model with like all the
mediator particles and all the matter
particles to be massless now here is the
standard model of particle physics as we
know it with the matter constituents on
the left hand side the quartz we've been
talking about the electrons which you
all know part of the atoms and the
electrons cousins the green particles on
the right-hand side we have the quantity
mediate interactions between these
particles the Z and the W of the weak
force the photon which we all know a
love and the gluons and the theory would
like all these particles to be massless
however we all know they are not
massless I mean we are not massless
unfortunately for some so something must
be there in the background to give this
particle mass and this is symbolized by
this gray Club in the background here
with an H on top so how can the world be
so diverse what is the origin of mass
now the problem is that to make the
standard model work we need
which are basically symmetrical but
these symmetries forbid particles to
have mass if you try to put in mass by
hand into the theories the theories will
collapse then and the standard model no
longer works so somehow the symmetries
must be broken in such a way that keeps
the good properties of the theory now
this is where the Mexican hat comes in
and I believe that everyone has seen
this picture of the Mexican hat now the
Mexican hat symbolizes asymmetry if you
think in terms of a hat you see a hat in
front of you and suppose you had the bag
which sits on top in the center of the
hat to you all the world look symmetric
all directions are equivalent however if
you slide down into the valley then the
world is no longer symmetric there's
obviously one direction in which it's
easy to move which is around the center
and there are directions in which
there's difficult it's difficult to move
and it's alarm up and along the brim and
so now we have a situation which was
symmetric to begin with but which is no
longer symmetric now this Mexican hat
symbolizes illustrates a piece of
mathematics the broad angle Aaron Hicks
added into the theory to show that you
could have a theory which was inherently
symmetric but where the ground stayed
the state of the lowest energy did not
display the symmetry and this is what
saved the standard model now the summit
the theory made a concrete prediction
namely one there should exist a new
fundamental particle and to all the
other particles in nature the matter
particles and the quantum mediating
forces should gain Mars three
interactions
with these particles which brings us
back to the 4th of July 2012 appearing
in front of a packed auditorium at CERN
the spokespersons of the experiments
Atlas and CMS announced the observation
of a new fundamental particles in
proton-proton collisions at the Large
Hadron Collider which had properties
consistent with the long sought after
Higgs particle and you can imagine that
the whole added to auditorium explored
it enough floors now here you see again
Higgs and angler waving to the
auditorium after the announcement of the
observation had been made now what I'm
going to show you is what the evidence
for the existence of a new fundamental
Higgs particle looks like this is a
little bit difficult so I ask you to
have a little bit of patience
so we have a diagram here showing on the
horizontal axis the mass
okay now the Higgs particle cannot be
seen directly it can only be
reconstructed from its decays from
traces it lives in particles but
particle detectors so from these traces
you can reconstruct the particle mass
but it is not clear it comes out exactly
in one point you can get many different
masses so on the horizontal Mar on the
horizontal axis you have the
reconstructed mass on the vertical axis
you have the number of events found at
each mass there is another caveat namely
their background their processes
mimicking the Higgs which are not the
Higgs particles they are not the
processes you after and they will be
shown in blue in this diagram so what
you are going to look for is a red peak
appearing in data against the blue
background and I'm going to show you how
the data evolved with time the black
points will be die
and so look for the red peek and try to
follow the time development so here you
see it comes up as more and more data
collected you see the blue background
growing fast but also the small red peak
appearing and this is the observation of
the Higgs particle now this is not the
data they had in 2012 now I'm showing
you all the data we accumulated unto the
shutdown of LHC in the beginning of 2013
so I think I can stop this this is what
the data looks like we see the red Higgs
peak on the blue background and so what
we have here is the final piece in the
puzzle which is the standard model this
is of course not the final piece in the
puzzle of the universe there's still
mysteries left we don't know what the
dark masses we don't know what the dark
energy is we don't know if he is the
only Higgs particle to exist of there's
more Higgs particles so obviously there
are things to do for future generations
of scientists thank you Thank You
professor Boatner we will not see if you
can get hold of a professor on glare I
just talked to him a few minutes ago
yeah are you there with us professor on
glare good day and congratulation how do
you feel right now well thank you very
much I feel very well of course I I
thought first I had to make the low
festivity because I thought that I
didn't see any announcement that I
didn't have it yes some sitting here in
the session hall at the Royal Swedish
Academy of Sciences and I have a large
group of people from media in the
international press
are you ready to take some questions
from the press professor on glass please
I will try to do what I can okay
yes hello my name is Maria gone through
accent song I'm writing for the Swedish
newspaper doggins Nieto and you and I
met this summer in Stockholm if you
remember and congratulations to the
prize yes and I have a question for you
now when the standard model is complete
what is the biggest cause now that the
standard model is complete yeah which in
your opinion is the biggest question
remaining to be sold in physics well
there are a few big questions right
first the question which is still not
solved is whether there is some broken
supersymmetry which will manifest itself
that energy will not yet been reached
this is the critical point for what will
happen but of course there are other
problems like some of them may be
directly related some other indirectly
or maybe not related which is the
problem of dark matter is probably
somehow hopefully related to particle
physics the problem of dark energy is a
more tricky problem which one way or
another regions to what is in my opinion
the most and the fundamental problem
which is not so today despite some
progress which is a problem of quantum
gravity of the quantization of the
question hi so congratulations my name
is Conti enough in The Times of India
very interestingly the press release
here starts with a lie
says here at last professor how true is
that I'm sorry I was saying talks about
the first line in the release says here
at last how true is that
[Music]
maybe it's my you have a question yeah
you have it do we have a micro
microphone
congratulations my name is Jonah rose
i'm swedish popular science magazine
fortune from sting and i would like to
ask you in the late 60s when you worked
on the theory did you ever think about
the discovery of the Higgs boson oh yes
but the whole thing at that time
when first the late 60 is not really
when the thing was done it was the
beginning of the sixties and 64 it was
published after a lot of thought at that
time we saw that we're going to solve
this way the problem of shortage forces
which was completely and sold in that
time and which obviously is related to
the problem of the origin of mass so the
boson by itself is something that is the
experimental test of the existence of
the whole mechanism and one had to wait
certainly we had to wait first before
the theory itself was applied to
something which is a standard model
which took some time it had took some
time to first prove the consistency
which was 17 during the 17th 7
understand that model was better done
and only after that could one look for a
test because the standard model was
wonderfully very fine except for the
missing element which was that boson
whose condensation is what gives the
okay do we have another question please
yes hi congratulations this is Marlon
from The Associated Press of course this
was highly anticipated by all of us how
did you feel when you found out about
the award and what are you planning to
do with the prize money the second
question I don't know just how does it
feel to want a Nobel Prize I mean well
you may imagine that this is not very
unpleasant thank you
ok I think we have a finally question
there hello this is David Landis with
the local here in Stockholm
congratulations professor angler a
question about your your co-winner
I'm wondering when you last spoke with
Professor Higgs and what you plan to say
to him when you see him next
I saw him was in
the fourth of July conference at CERN we
never met before and but since then we
met and we met in particularly the EBS
conference and what I'm going to say to
him of course I'm going to congratulate
him because I think it's very important
and excellent work okay
thank you very much and thank you very
much I think this was the last question
from from the press here and thank you
professor on glare and once again
congratulations and we look forward to
see you in Stockholm in December for the
Nobel Prize ceremony yeah thank you
thank you bye so order now any questions
about the physics prize and the research
involved that you will pose to the panel
here question I have a question there
Florence tell ya the highly oxidized
story at the see a number of manioc so
Vioxx well it's still experimental
experimental success the same story who
rethink the Committee on ammonium today
a lot of places haven't seen no longer
EPS and terms for experimental program
stands today so care to shake up a surah
you know they are first was did restores
in through orgasm can scope and brought
us Estella say it all okay so at a some
committee and her attitude going through
and they are first affirms that
innovates to Samantha Sinatra nominee
Rinna was Ana de Flore Ganim preset
study who know prestige all that the
task in under discussion on a committee
Anna
sense or haviar Siham not poetry special
accommodation Lucia it are or the
cluttered them internally
and I come in on committee 9 thing so we
can have Slayer film film Deewar did you
reach Professor Peter Higgs did you
speak to actually we tried quite hard to
get hold of him but of all the numbers
we tried he did not answer so a so hope
he would know this by now we are of
course sending him an information right
now by email so he would have it also
but but I have not been able to talk to
him
unfortunately so is this why the
announcement was delayed or was there
another reason I can't comment on that
but but I just tell you it's it's it's
it's very important to stress that it is
today that the Academy decides on the
Nobel Prize it's no other day so this
has happened just a few meters from this
session hall
okay are the more questions and if not
thank you very much for your attention
and we hope to see you back on Wednesday
at 11:45 earliest I think you have to
look at that earliest for the new
announcement of the Nobel Prize in
Chemistry 2013 thank you very much
[Music]
Oh
olga Bachner this year's price must have
been the most anticipated price in the
Nobel Prizes history so why did we have
to wait for more than an hour
for the press conference oh you have to
understand that this the decision about
the prize is taken from the very same
day when it is not so there was a
discussion and there should be a
discussion otherwise if the price is so
anticipated and no one in the Academy
even have to come to the decision mid
meeting and today there were a number of
people there and there was a very good
discussion and he landed on this prize
because in ours these are two scientists
actually wrote the theory in the 60s
1964 so they had to wait even longer for
the prize
well you know there is a lot of theories
out there and I'm gonna experimental it
myself so you have to understand that my
attitude church theorist is okay so
there's a fear there a lot of theories
out there there's a lot of theories out
there but in the end it's the interplay
between experiment and theory which
decides what nature has chosen as the
grand scheme
and so it took 15 years for the
prediction they made in 1964 to turn out
to come true and the thing which makes
the prize interesting right now you
asking why 50 years is because of this
observation of a new particle at CERN
where the properties expected them by
the theory so this is why sometimes I
have to wait 50 years and sometimes the
theory may turn out to not be true this
is this so-called Higgs particle many
people have heard about it but why was
it so hard together to discover it well
there are several things one thing is
that the theory predicted that there
ought to be a particle it could tell us
the properties of this particle so how
it interacted with other particles with
matter particles and force carrier
particles but it couldn't tell us what
the mass of this particle was and so we
didn't know where to look and so
actually for the past 50 years this
particle has been looked for at every
accelerator in existence so it has been
looked for the eyesore it has been
looking for the sps at CERN
at the left Collider at the temperature
this is this was an ongoing harness so
from other properties one could try to
narrow the range of mass and what bit so
both of them at 11:00 and the Tevatron
so in the end we knew more or less that
if it existed it had to be bad and then
the LHC came in it is the most powerful
accelerator in existence could produce
enough energy to make this happen and so
we found the particle
where is this person important
well the particle in itself is not as
important as the theory which is
represents so the theory tells us why we
exist because as I said in my talk this
is a philosophical question then again
but maybe tells us why we don't float
away like the photo I mean we all know
that we are massive we know that we
consist of atoms and atoms and atomic
utilize protons and electrons and
neutrons this is what we consist of but
according to the theories which existed
before the mechanism was proposed all
these particles ought to have been
massless and we know that unfortunately
we are massive from a more massive
learner people but definitely not
massless so there is something wrong and
the theory proposed their solution and
this is where the theory is important
and the particles is important as a
manifestation of
so all quarters get the masses from the
Higgs field the Higgs field theory and
where does this Higgs particle exist is
it here around us where is it well I
have to modify this a little bit all
particles that we consist of get mass
from the Higgs particle they're
particles which do not seem to interact
with the Higgs particle names in which
she knows and so the standard model is
not completely complete there it is
probably only a low-energy approximation
of something larger which also explains
the mass of the neutrinos which also
explains the dark matter so the moment
we don't know but electrons and protons
and neutrons the quartz inside them get
masked by interaction interacting with
the Higgs so one way of looking at is to
imagine that the Higgs field is
something which pervades all the
universe it's everywhere it's here in
the room it's out in in the black space
it's everywhere and so every particle
moves through this field and it's forced
to will interact with the Higgs
particles in that way yes now all the
time
and we don't see we don't feel mean we
are born like that right so you wouldn't
we wouldn't feel the fear but where does
this feel then the protocol come from
well this is something that we actually
don't know I mean this must have
happened in the Big Bang somehow that
this is how our universe is constructed
that there is this field it is possible
that this field was part of the
inflation process would blow up the
universe from a very tiny size to what
we have today we also don't know that we
don't know there's only one Higgs field
or maybe there's more he excuse so there
still miss was dissolved if this Higgs
particle is so crucial to the whole the
universe and the discovery was so hard
to make why didn't the people who made
the discovery get the Nobel Prize well
this is as you know it's a very
difficult question for me to answer
because we I know it not that liberty to
divulge the discussions which take place
inside a Nobel Committee or inside in DD
Academy when the decision is made but
let me just tell you the decision on the
prize is based on primarily the tests up
there the will of Alfred Nobel on the
nominations which we received this very
year and then we of course take into
account the prestige and tradition of
the prize and weighing all these things
together we came up up with
the proposal of this year's price and
now for the rest of the internal
discussion you will have to wait for two
you spoke to just wearing glare one of
the lorentz but not to Peter leaks will
you try to call him again yes we're
going to try to call him later today and
actually I think we left a message of
his recorder that we have not that the
Academy that have been trying to call
him but the Stockholm has been trying to
call him and we hope that he'll respond
but the rumour has it that he has gone
into hiding for the rest of the week in
anticipation that you know since this
price was so anticipated he knew that in
either case if he gets it there will be
press storm if he doesn't get it there
will also be a press storm so it felt
like it was better to go into hiding the
Higgs particle has been said to be the
last piece of the standard model puzzle
for elementary particle physics its
particle physics
oh the standard model is contained so
far so good but as I already told you
there's still unsold things one is the
neutrinos they somehow don't fit
completely into the standard model they
do have mass but apparently they're not
getting their mass through interactions
with means there's also the question why
the Higgs is so light maybe there are
more more Higgs particle maybe this is
just one of them and are more to be
found
so today the belief is that the standard
model is a low-energy approximation of a
more complete theory and this whole
complete theory is what particle physics
is after now so there are various
speculations supersymmetry
maybe a possible extension of the
standard model they're also people
speaking of extra dimensions so that our
four-dimensional world is just what we
perceive of a larger ten dimensional
worlds and the other dimensions I just
tiny rolled up and we don't see them so
there are many speculations out there
and like with the Higgs you know
experiment will eventually show which
theory
[Music]